welcome to this video playing then input
again yeah I don't know I always have
problems with this guy let's see so this
is some group felt something like like
that with d-4d for was the room felt
this now is an English opening hmm how
is this plate I think you can actually
take be too but i forgot i forgotten how
to do it okay so night to d3 just here
now i don't know i have completely
forgotten how this is so this is played
right before and night see forearm I
interesting i think i'm already in a bit
of a troll here ah what the heck
especially 94 it just winds the porn
here how do i prevent that
now still 94 okay well okay yeah yeah I
can I can move the Queen at least and
hope that I get some counterplay maybe
with this move so it's really before
it's idea I die okay at least I'm i
would have out of this and i can drop
back here okay I think I'm okay I'm okay
I had some some some big trouble he has
some awesome not some bit varies I mean
here that I wouldn't survive the opening
here okay so be 5985 it's not great okay
maybe just
keep it simple if you take so I can't
even take with a real concern it's okay
also just maybe I hope threatening to
take on c4 Bishop text e-textbook takes
winning upon mmm i Luke c8 how this
isn't too bad maybe or maybe I'm
completely not understanding all this
but ok well this this cannot be great
for what no way ever ok at least I can
take c4 and windy a poner como I do that
it's it's it's good at simple it's upon
me and the airport is supported of
course by by my bishop some
okay here we go let's move the April
come on let's push it ooh k 7i can I can
also have I can give this check here
I is what Kiev is got Queen wolf we have
one
I forgot what Queen f1 this is stupid I
don't tell me i blundered the apron oh
Christ
how idiotic
I just thought Queens Queen check and a
three and he's got kooky we never won ah
what the heck okay unbelievable
yep that's that's that's always cool
those opponents who play the first half
of the game like like they're just out
of the roots course I it then they
played great this is just the best move
from keeping everything under control
yeah laughs no cackling here it's just
what okay this just like I told first
half of the game like like I don't know
how and then all of a subject not sure
what's going on here
sir
that's its and yet another Queen here
two queens check
check
yeah with 20 seconds this is terrible
any time warning
check
check
check
check and of course you won't agree to a
draw it is completely dead but of course
I deserve to lose this after how crappy
I played that's completely black
perfectly fine completely dead of course
but yeah well for some reason it doesn't
have increment Here I am so let's let's
um I mean they're just a complete idiot
what the heck I mean it didn't make any
sense all of this just if I don't push
the apron I'm just winning I play for my
team place all these moves Quincy five
is strong I didn't see that one okay
Quincy five was winning as well so here
can I'm curious what happened here yeah
man check and this was just I don't
understand any of that I'm done I'm just
just completely winning here over 20
seconds the four pawns I'm a tricky very
tricky it's a very compact set up here
the way it went down it was a drone but
check here because white is winning what
he didn't of course it's not necessary
with this time control to make good
moves you just need to win on time check
then therefore he doesn't didn't even
try to check to win this is of course
dead ok so I spotted multiple times
right here the easiest was to to play
this this Quincy five but I didn't spot
this b5 track this is really neat Quincy
five we should pay for me five alright
thanks for watching